le président de la république aso a
choisi chanonat pour s'adresser demain
soir au pays
mitterrand marché par chirac dernière
intervention
la réponse appartient maintenant aux
français les commentaires d'alain
duhamel
pour ce renversement de tendance des
valeurs françaises elles gagnent de 1 à
3%
première entreprise d'ordinateurs
d'europe honeywell bull organise
l'opération estimations de la soirée
spéciale élections antenne d'euros.la
messieurs bonsoir il parlera il parlera
demain je parle bien sûr de
l'intervention du président de
république à la veille du premier tour
intervention qui avait suscité beaucoup
d'interrogations depuis quelques jours
pour reprendre les termes mêmes du
communiqué de l'elysée le chef de l'état
rappellera l'enjeu du choix des français
il devrait développer d'une manière plus
synthétique l'essentiel des thèmes de
verdun sur le doubs intervention
symbolique dans sa forme puisque le
président qui doit voter dimanche à
chanonat dans le puy-de-dôme parlera à
la télévision à cette même heure depuis
l'auvergne il l'a déjà fait deux fois
mais n'était pas à l'époque à l'elysée
commentaire du premier ministre raymond
barre il est normal quand les grandes
circonstances le prénom république
intervienne en dehors de tout esprit
partisan
telle n'est pas l'opinion de françois
mitterrand qui interrogé par notre
reporter à daniel grandclément à
l'occasion d'un déjeuner de presse à
perpignan a protesté contre la date
choisie pour cette intervention du chef
de l'état se trouve un peu surprenant
que le président de la république non
pas qu'ils s'expriment mais qu'ils
puissent s'exprimer en dehors des règles
du jeu qu'il a lui-même fixé
voilà le pad d'autre chose à dire sinon
peut-être des considérations de
caractère psychologique
le président la république s'exprimant à
la dernière heure samedi soir alors que
les électrices et que les électeurs sont
conviés à se rendre dans les bureaux de
vote dès le dimanche matin montre bien
l'état d'inquiétude sinon de
décomposition de laquelle se trouvent
les partis conservateurs qui pense avoir
plus que ce recours la le président de
la république
je comprends ce réflexe de la part des
partis conservateurs qui sont à l'heure
actuelle en fin de course
je comprends moins le réflexe du
président de la république qui eût avant
la ville mieux fait sans que j'exagère
les choses n'est que sans que je crée
une situation de crispation parfaitement
inutiles les françaises les françaises
savent ce qu'ils doivent faire est
vraiment j'aurais préféré que le
président la république se situe en tant
qu'orateur de la majorité dans le cadre
des dispositions légales qui ont été
prises à cet effet on se mettait en qui
par ailleurs a estimé possible et
souhaitable une rencontre entre les
trois partenaires du programme commun
pour respecter un parfait équilibre
surtout à l'avant veille d'un scrutin
décisif je vous dis tout de suite que
nous entendrons ce soir les quatre
dernières interventions des quatre
grandes la campagne après françois
mitterrand donc à perpignan georges
marchais qui depuis une heure est
l'invité des journalistes du club de la
presse d'europe 1 je pense que la
réunion de lundi sera couronnée de
succès qu'il y aura accord et que nous
veillerons le 19 dans la mesure où il y
a
accord avec nos partenaires socialistes
et radicaux sur le programme est sur
deux gouvernements nous participerons au
gouvernement il y aura des ministres
communistes il y aura pas besoin
d'attendre le vin pour le savoir en
votant le 19 pour le candidat unique de
la gauche
dans le cas où il y aura eu cet accord
les gens voteront pour un gouvernement
qui comprendra des ministres communistes
si les résultats du 12 répondait votre
attente mais que malgré cela le 13 au
soir le 14 mai mme l'accord ne soit pas
complet par exemple sur le gouvernement
ou sur certains points encore du
programme
que se passait-il jose espérait que le
parti socialiste ne prendra pas la
responsabilité de désespérer les
travailleurs si la victoire est à la
portée de la main compte tenu que nous
nous ne formulons aucune exigence aucune
exigence excessive nous demandons
simplement respect du programme commun
de 1972
pour ce qui concerne le programme pour
ce qui concerne le gouvernement accord
de principe il s'agit pas de négocier
dans l'union dans le détail de la
répartition des ministères évidemment
accord de principe sur les règles
gouvernementales
par conséquent disons que ce que nous
demandons n'est pas excessif il serait
grave pour ce très grave pour le parti
socialiste de refuser des propositions
aussi sage aussi raisonnable qui n'ont
pas donc pour l'opposition du côté de la
majorité à retenir cette interview de
michel debré dans valeurs actuelles
une victoire de la gauche aux élections
entraînerait une grave crise de régime
à retenir aussi le dernier meeting
électoral de raymond barre qu'il a
réservé à sa circoncision du rhône
bernard pradines au surplace a choisi un
extrait de cette dernière intervention
du premier ministre
l'alternance nous sommes prêts à
l'accepter mais nous ne voulons pas au
prix 20 suicides collectifs
ne vous laissez pas prendre au piège du
changement sont rice
vous entendez le double langage
vous voyez le double visage de ce qui
explique que ma foi on verra bien les
socialistes laissé tomber certaines
parties du programme commun puis ensuite
constitué le meilleur rempart contre le
communisme
alors pourquoi cherche-t-il à l'heure
actuelle à être élu grâce aux voix
communistes
est ce que monsieur mitterrand c'est
monsieur ramadier
monsieur jules moch de vous ne vous
laissez pas prendre à ce raisonnement
selon lequel on pourra faire un petit
tour dans l'opposition et qu'un jour
nous reprendrons nos affaires en main
parce que le président de la république
leur a dissous l'assemblée nationale
rappelez vous ce que le président de la
république a dit à verdun sur le doubs
si vous votez pour l'application du
programme commun le programme commun
sera appliquée car je n'ai pas les
moyens constitutionnels demi opposée
sous prétexte que dans six mois
vous pourriez redevenir maîtres du jeu
n'accusait pas le président de la
république à l'impuissance
ne laissez pas se produire des dégâts
irrémédiables qui en six mois
ruinerait les efforts de 30 ans
donc la dernière intervention du premier
ministre qui est aussi candidat à lyon
vous le savez quant à jacques chirac le
dernier de ce qu'on a appelé un petit
peu et irrévérencieusement la bande des
quatre est bien jacques chirac avait lui
aussi réservé son dernier meeting pour
ses électeurs de corrèze il va parler
dans quelques minutes avec le temps
jacques chirac suivi toute la soirée
d'hier par claude sérillon et cela a
commencé là aussi au club de la presse
d'europe 1
devant les journalistes le début de la
soirée calme les uns et les autres se
connaissent le président du rpr
tranquille souri au hasard d'une
question il confie je suis le contraire
d'un exhibitionniste quelques mots
quelques phrases encore répété déjà
entendu discrètement on avale des petits
pains dorés puis sur l'estrade sous un
chapiteau dressé à l'ombre de la tour
montparnasse
c'est déjà un autre discours
l'enthousiasmé n'est plus ce qu'il était
mais tout de même moyenne merci merci de
tout coeur venus si nombreux ce soir on
nous apportait la chaleur de votre ego
fort et aussi le témoignage de votre
détermination et votre volonté de ne pas
accepter je ne sais quelle fatalité qui
conduirait la france sur les voies de
laventure merci merci à toutes et à tous
et bbc
jacques chirac 500 huitième n'est pas
dernière au cirque d'hiver il est tard
au dessus de la piste le maire de paris
ça et là des bonnets phrygiens dans les
gradins ni le décor ni les idées n'ont
vraiment changé depuis le début de la
campagne électorale de jacques chirac
voilà donc ce qu'ont dit les quatre
grands à nous maintenant de faire le
point la nouvelle avait d'abord cette
attitude de nouvelles du prion d'un
public l'intervention dans la campagne
qu'est ce que cela peut changer oui
alors je laisse de côté l'aspect
constitutionnel on sait que c'est
toujours un sujet de controverse
d'ailleurs bien de le voir le problème
le problème des effets que ça produit
alors on ces trois choses on sait 1 que
la france qui est susceptible de varier
la frange de l'électorat est limité bon
on sait d'eux que pour qu' elle soit
touché il faut que ce soit au dernier
moment puisque les effets d'un discours
de ce genre que quel que soit son
notaire d'ailleurs c'est trois jours au
maximum donc le lendemain salle était
maximale harley davidson
et puis on sait troisième nom ce qui est
important que à partir du moment où
comme c'est le cas
majorité et opposition sont vraiment au
coude à coude
même si ça ne touchait par hypothèse que
1% des voix donc en fait ça fait 2 %
dans les deux sens ça peut être
déterminant à dire autant qu'on sache
est ce que la frange des dissidents pas
importante
a priori la france tout à fait après ce
qu on sait la frange des indécis n'est
pas très importante mais en revanche il
reste un point d'interrogation ce qui
est autre chose quel pourcentage
d'abstention et ce à tous les moyens
dont on dispose sont toujours médiocre
pour le mesurer
alors que ce fameux réflexe du dernier
moment sur fx de l'isoloir existe
vraiment alors je crois pas qu'il dresse
de l'isoloir mais en revanche il ya un
réflexe des trois derniers jours on
trouve toujours cette idée de trois
jours pendant les trois derniers jours
on sait qu'il ya toujours des
modifications de vote
d'ailleurs dans les deux sens et jamais
de façon équilibrée il ya toujours 100
par les sondages parce qu'on n'a pas le
droit
quel est l'état des forces à la veille
de ce premier tour bon alors là dessus
les choses sont claires pour le premier
tour la gauche est en tête dans quelles
proportions c'est ce qu'on verra
dimanche soir mais elle est en tête et
elle est en tête grâce à la poussée du
parti socialiste car pour l'instant ce
qui concerne le parti communiste on ne
voit pas de signes qui est poussé le
ministre bon pour le second tour
là on sait déjà deux choses premièrement
que les reports de voix alain dire la
majorité se feront bien et se feront
bien pour deux raisons d'une part parce
que l'électorat de la majorité et plus
unitaire que l'électorat de la gauche
et deuxièmement parce que comme la
majorité sera mené à l'issue du premier
tour il y aura donc à un réflexe de
cohésion forcément
donc si vous voulez mécaniquement la
majorité reprendra de toute façon du
terrain pour le second tour par rapport
au premier alors la question est quelle
heure pour moi assez alors ça je dirais
que pour l'essentiel
ça dépend en fait du report de voix de
l'électorat du parti communiste sur les
sociétés alors sa deuxième question
justement l'hypothèque de l'attitude
communiste avoué est-ce qu'on peut les
préjugés un petit peu dans tes déjà
saoul et la probabilité pour ce qu'on
sait la probabilité c'est que le parti
communiste accepte désistement cesson
tout cas ce que dans la classe politique
les commentateurs on pense le plus
fréquemment
d'abord parce que il est difficile de
promettre beaucoup de choses à beaucoup
de gens et puis brusquement d'année
moment de ne pas le faire car c'est lui
oui c'est ça c'est beau manifestement
c'est difficile
d'autre part parce qu'effectivement le
climat a un petit peu changé ces jours
ci s est améliorée apparemment à gauche
bon alors ce qui est important c'est que
en pratique un l'électorat communiste et
le plus discipliné tout c'est à dire que
si le pc dire portez-vous ils se
reportent si le pc se maintient il se
maintient une proportion plus faible
mais il se maintient quand même aussi
donc si vous voulez c'est vraiment là
que vont se jouer pour l'essentiel le
second tour de même que pour le premier
l'intervention du président peut peut
toucher sur une branche de toute façon
réponses dont 4 ème un soir dimanche à
22h30 avec la constance de traces de
georges marchais et puis je vous
rappelle que cette campagne électorale
officielle va s'achever dans trois
heures et 50 minutes à minuit très
précisément ça nous sera au moins le
temps de souffler un petit peu demain
samedi
la bourse elle aussi a fermé ses portes
mais elle fonctionnera quand même entre
les deux tours ont fait savoir les
agents de change
la bourse qui a vu les valeurs
françaises se redresser aujourd'hui
après quatre jours consécutifs de baisse
elles enregistrent une hausse de l'ordre
d'un pour cent
léger raffermissement du franc également
à la veille du week-end électoral
le franc qui je vous l'avais dit avait
été attaqué hier à la veille des
élections présidentielles en 1974 mais
les sondages étaient encore officiel et
annie la bourse avait gagné 1% valéry
giscard d'estaing
étant donné gagnant au lendemain des
élections municipales l'an passé la
bourse avait perdu 5%
depuis quelques jours la bourse prête
une oreille plus attentive aux sondages
les plus divers alors qu'il attribue à
de ces sondages semi clandestin qui font
frissonner des dîners parisiens la bonne
tenue de la bourse d'aujourd'hui quoi
qu'il en soit pour la dernière séance
avant le premier tour des élections les
valeurs françaises qu'elles aient perdu
4% depuis le début de la semaine ont
repris du poil de la bête et puis il ya
deux autres explications plus techniques
d'abord la baisse de l'or est plus aussi
la présence massive des gendarmes c'est
à dire des investisseurs institutionnels
du camp investisseur public autour de la
corbeille quoi qu'il en soit on dit en
bourse de ces lundi et les boursiers
prenons vraiment position ces dernières
heures de campagne dotée aussi
l'occasion de multiples incidents le
plus grave d'entre eux datant de cette
nuit à toulon où le député sortant
bernard lafon du mouvement démocrate a
été victime d'une grave agression au
moment où il quittait son appartement
pour se rendre à son travail
agression également à argenteuil contre
un candidat rpr claude rolland il semble
qu'il s'agisse de colleurs d'affichés
mécontents de ne pas avoir été engagé
par lui et puis une série de procès en
diffamation de candidats entre eux à
paris un candidat d'extrême gauche a été
condamné pour diffamation envers le
communiste henry fiszbin et puis à lyon
monsieur bara été relaxés par le
tribunal
il était poursuivi par son concurrent
socialiste un mot maintenant sur notre
grande soirée de dimanche cette
opération électorale europe1 antenne 2
que vous pourrez suivre grâce aux cartes
de l'hygiène publié par le point
opération que nous avons pu monter
également grâce à honeywell bull qui à
20 heures précises nous fournira et vous
fournira une estimation chiffrée avec un
ordinateur peut-il donc tout calcul et
même une élection législative et en
donner avant la fin du dépouillement les
résultats globaux c'est le pari que va
tenir ces deuxièmes nouvelle bulle qui
va faire traiter par ces machines
les données recueillies sur un
échantillon choisi de 450 bureaux de
vote dans chacun de ses 450 bureaux
nous avons un correspondant qui est
chargée de surveiller le dépouillement
des résultats dès qu'il connaît des
résultats
il téléphone à notre siège social à
paris
et là les résultats communiqués sont
enregistrés par les téléphonistes et des
opératrices de terminaux
ces résultats sont immédiatement
transmis à l'ordinateur dès que les nos
experts de sciences politiques estiment
que la moisson la récolte des bureaux de
vote est suffisante
il déclenche dans l'ordinateur la chaîne
d'exploitation qui aboutit à la
publication des résultats de
l'estimation et ses résultats de
l'estimation seront immédiatement
transmis au palais bourbon
plus précisément à l'hôtel de lassay où
sera installée antenne 2 il s'agit au
fond de représenter l'ensemble des
sensibilités politiques des sensibilités
régionales également de tenir compte de
la répartition des habitants entre les
villes et les campagnes de façon non pas
à voir si vous voulez des bureaux moyens
qui donnerait chacun la moyenne de la
recongeler au contraire d'avoir toute la
palette des opinions représentées
ceci nous permet de à partir de cet
échantillon de faire l'hypothèse que les
musulmans qui apparaissent grâce à notre
échantillon sont